profiler markt hofmann jetzt bei mir im
studio dieser neueste fall ist leider
nur einer von vielen in der jüngsten
vergangenheit woher kommt diese spirale
der gewalt in den usa wie kann man sich
diese erklären
zu dem thema ungern weil es teilweise
von beiden seiten aus wohl von seiten
der polizei als auch von seiten der
demonstranten hoch emotional geworden
ist und ich probier's analyst mehr
fakten anzuschauen ohne sie zu werten
oder dem sozusagen eine emotionale
komponente zu geben aber eine sache muss
man mal klar sagen ja es gibt ein
strukturelles rassismus problemen in den
usa auch bei der polizei und das buy in
dem fall george freut muss man auch
vollkommen klar sagen das war mord
und ich denke auch das wäre einem weißen
nicht passiert das heißt es war
rassistisch motiviert das ist ja auch
noch mal ein zweiter wichtiger zusatz in
dem fall ist das eindeutig aber es ist
nicht in jedem fall eindeutig man muss
jeden fall einzeln anschauen nicht jede
tat wenn das ein weißer polizist und ein
schwarzes opfer ist nicht jedes mal ist
es mord und nicht jedes mal ist es
rassismus die polizei ein gewaltmonopol
und natürlich dürfen und müssen sie sich
selbst schützen und in manchen
situationen sind schüsse auch
gerechtfertigt deswegen muss man auch da
den einzelfall auf jeden fall anschauen
wenn wir hier auf den einzelfall geben
ist sind laut anwalt mehr als 20 schüsse
gewesen die polizei sagt es waren
weniger sagen aber auch nicht es waren
nur drei oder in dieser größe menge
deswegen da die konkrete frage 20
schüsse dafür gibt es doch eigentlich
keine erklärung
es ging um ein radfahrer verstoß das ist
rassistisch oder nicht einfach falsch
richtig
es ging um ein rad fahrradfahrer verstoß
aber die person hatte auch eine
halbautomatische waffe dabei und das ist
natürlich auch ein fakt den man nicht
unterschätzen darf aber ich denke schon
man muss zwei fragen stellen erstens war
das fehlverhalten also hat die polizei
sich falsch verhalten war das mord war
das totschlag war das unangemessene
gewalt und die zweite frage wenn es
unangemessen war es die zweite frage war
das rassistisch motiviert auf den ersten
blick ich habe oft die jetzt die meldung
gehört radfahrer von polizei mit 20
schüssen niedergeschossen da denkt man
sofort das ist wieder ist es ist ein
afroamerikaner das ist rassistisch
motiviert aber der fakt mit einer
halbautomatischen waffe bringt ein
bisschen eine andere komponente
allerdings hat er sich nicht nach der
waffe gezückt das heißt er die waffe
fallen gelassen
und er hat sich nach den aktuellen
informationen nicht danach gebückt und
da muss man schon die frage stellen war
es überhaupt nötig zu schießen und wenn
es nötig war zu schießen ist die polizei
nicht auch darauf ausgebildet leute ja
unfähig zu machen zu flüchten statt sie
immer gleich zu töten und da muss ich
schon sagen ist die wahrscheinlichkeit
sehr groß dass es fehlverhalten war aber
das einzige was ich bisher gesehen habe
war ein verwackeltes 30 sekündige zeugen
ein handy video und ich muss auch sagen
dass ich seriös anhand des videos nicht
erkennen kann ob das ob das
fehlverhalten war gab es noch eine
zweite waffe gab und ob es wirklich 20
schüsse waren oder nicht
da kursieren auch unterschiedliche
informationen aber diese beiden fragen
muss man auch jedes mal stellen erstens
war es fehlverhalten und zweitens war es
wenn es fehlverhalten war rassistisch
motiviert oder nicht aber george floyd
blake jetzt dieser fall
man erkennt leider schon ein muster und
kann nicht sagen dass das immer alles
einzelfälle sind ja ohne auf details
einzugehen vielleicht eine nachfolge
noch sie haben gerade jacob black auch
angesprochen der mit sieben schüssen in
den rücken von der polizei jetzt in den
rollstuhl gebracht worden ist aber
überlebt hat auch in dem fall gab es
natürlich große proteste amerika kommt
seit george freund eigentlich gar nicht
mehr zur ruhe was macht das für ein
spannungsverhältnis zwischen den
menschen vor allem zwischen
afroamerikanern zwischen schwarzen und
der polizei wenn man ja doch gar kein
vertrauen mehr haben können die menschen
eigentlich schützen sollten
leider ist es so dass immer die
radikalen oftmals die deutungshoheit
über eine ganze gruppe bekommen zum
beispiel in diesem fall wir sprechen
jetzt über diese zwei polizisten aber
schnell wird dann die gesamte polizei
und sozusagen unter diesem blickwinkel
gesehen
zwei leute verhalten sich falsch und die
gesamte polizei gerät unter
generalverdacht ja es gibt ein
strukturelles problem aber sie müssen
auch die identifizieren die wirklich
dafür verantwortlich sind
und ich kenne selber viele polizisten in
den usa den liegt rassismus so fern wie
nichts anderes abgesehen davon dass sie
selbst zum großen teil afro amerikaner
sind und da ist es einfach absurd die
polizei unter generalverdacht zu stellen
aber leider ist es so dass innerhalb der
demonstranten über wen wird berichtet
über die drei radikalen die dann auch
auf polizisten losgehen spucken und was
auch immer tun
die große menge die sehr gute absichten
und ein gutes anliegen hat sind eben
nicht so laut bei den polizisten
dasselbe die große menge der polizisten
die sich wir reden ja heute nicht
eilmeldung schwarzer wurde bei einer
fahrradkontrolle kontrolliert und laufen
gelassen dass er keine meldung aber
schwarzer der erschossen wird das ist
eine meldung afroamerikaner das heißt
wir reden immer über die die sich
fehlverhalten wir reden über die die
fehler machen und das ist oftmals die
tatsächlich innerhalb der polizei
rassistische minderheit die dann aber
das image stärken polizei massiv
runterzieht und es ist aber auch inhalte
demonstranten die minderheit der
radikalen die auch einfach geschäfte
plündern mehr mich hat mir ist der sinn
nicht ganz klar warum geschäfte plündern
oder scheiben einschlagen warum man
damit jetzt gegen rassismus kämpft oder
darauf aufmerksam machte erschließt sich
mir der zusammenhang auch nicht so ganz
aber es sind immer die radikalen die
deutungshoheit gewinnen und damit
überzeugt man keine seite die fronten
verhärten sich er und ich glaube je mehr
die polizei auch bespuckt oder von
einzelnen angegriffen wird desto
schlimmer wird es niemand sagt oh ich
habe heute bei der demonstration wohlig
angespuckt jetzt reflektiere ich mal
meine eigenen einstellungen und
überdenke mein rassismus leider wird es
nicht passieren